Okay let's count it out.
Product number one the new iphone sc and number two.
This is the new.
Even more amazing ipad air and finally number three
this is Mac studio and studio display I think I counted correctly
on Tuesday Apple held a pretty jam packed infomercial.
I mean media event and naturally they announced that all their products were incredible,
incredible,
incredible incredible incredible,
groundbreaking,
credible,
credible.
It's incredible new chip.
Okay okay let me set some expectations here.
Most of these new products are incremental updates to older products except for the
Mac's studio,
a crazy new desktop.
Let's break it all down.
Number one the iphone S.
E.
Here it is the brand new $429 iphone sc.
Just joking this is the model from two years ago but they look exactly the same.
So what's the big new update here?
A 15 bionic show.
A 15 bionic 8 15 and 8 15.
8 15.
Yes there was a lot of talk about the processor which is the same as the one in the iphone 13 models.
Apple said this will enable better performance and better battery life which is something you'll need with the addition
of 5G to our most affordable iPhone.
The new cellular connectivity should make downloading videos and files faster.
That is if you're in a 5G coverage area and you need to download seven seasons of
true blood in record time because emergencies happen really.
Five G.
Is not a reason to upgrade the reason to get the S.
C.
Is that it still has a home button and it's the most affordable iphone now at $429
though.
Up from $399.
The sc has a single 12 megapixel camera but the processor unlocks better photos and
features such as smart HDR four deep fusion and portrait mode.
You'll need to go up to the iphone 11 at 4 99 to get face I.
D.
And two cameras.
Or you can just go for the new green colored iphone.
Wait I mean sorry there's an alpine green for the iphone 13 pro and a green
green for the iphone 13 because what better way for Apple to boost high end iphone sales?
Midyear than with the color of money.
Okay fine.
I like the new color Number two.
The iPad air just like the iPhone.
The new iPad air looks like the old iPad air.
I bet you can guess what it's getting.
Ultra fast.
Five G.
Two ipad Air.
It also now has a faster M.
One processor Plus it has 2 12 megapixel ultra wide cameras,
one on the front and one on the back.
The front one now supports center stage When you're video calling the camera will pan to you in
frame and widen if someone else jumps in that said Apple still has the ipad webcam
positioned wrong for horizontal video calling just move the camera.
Apple Number three The Mac's Studio and Studio Display.
Okay here's the one I'm the most excited about for those who haven't been paying attention.
A few years ago,
Apple said it was going to transition its macs from intel chips to its own chips.
With our first chip designed specifically for the Mac and we
call it M one M one has been all the new M one
chips have made max faster and cooler as in temperature.
Now Apple's releasing em one ultra,
it is a monster of a chip and it brings breathtaking levels of performance to the Mac
desktop.
The new chip,
which is really to M one chips put together is eight times faster than the M one as this.
Apple executive said,
that's more than four times the bandwidth of the leading multi chip interconnect technology.
And this new Mac's studio is the first to get this new powerful ultra chip which can do all sorts of high
performance tasks.
Mac's studio can play an unprecedented 18 streams of eight
K pro rest for two to video.
The desktop looks bigger than the Mac mini and has room for all the ports you could possibly want
Guys to USB a ports in 2022.
It's crazy.
And here's my real favorite news of the day.
This crazy 27 inch five K studio display.
It has a built in 12 megapixel camera with center stage which should finally make video
calling on a Mac as good as it is on an iphone,
but since these are aimed at pros,
they're not cheap.
The Mac's studio starts at 1000 $999 with the M.
One Macs chip and starts at 3000 $999 with the M one ultra
chip.
The studio display starts at 1000 $599.
They will be available on March 18th.
It was a lot to take in.
They started with the most basic iphone at $429 and ended with a
$4000 ultra max studio.
So yeah,
consult your bank account and get back to me with some questions and to the person at Apple whose job it
is to come up with all these superlatives.
I just want to say amazing,
amazing,
groundbreaking.
It's amazing and amazing.
It's really amazing,
outstanding.